so Vampire Academy Vampire Academy is a
movie that I really wasn't planning on
seeing but I got an absurd amount of
requests to watch this movie and since I
decided well I'm gonna watch this thing
I dragged my girlfriend along my fiancee
but believe it or not she actually
wanted to see it too because we kind of
like to watch movie sometimes where we
walk into it and we know this probably
is not going to be an Oscar contender
it's kind of fun to rip them apart it's
kind of fun to have fun with them and we
actually had the entire theater to
ourselves we were the only two people in
the auditorium it was pretty awesome
yeah it was really nice we put our feet
up on the chairs and had my shoes off
and just kind of sitting there relaxing
it's kind of nice so the movie is
basically like a cross between Twilight
Harry Potter and Mean Girls and it
actually comes from the director of Mean
Girls basically these two girls that
have a bond with each other go to this
vampire Academy it's supposed to be a
high school despite the fact that
everyone looks like they're in college
and they act like they're in college too
cuz I certainly didn't do any of the
stuff they did in this when I was in
high school okay maybe one or two things
but that's about it so basically all
these kids are learning how to wield
magic and everyone's vampires there's
good vampires there's bad vampires and
of course there's love triangles and
backstabbings and all different types of
things going on and it all has that type
of Mean Girls feel to it where even
though there are vampires people say
stuff like biatch and things like that
current modern-day pop culture trends -
Sam before I tell you what I thought
about the movie what did you think of
the movie let him know well I thought
the movie was laughable it was so bad I
was laughing the entire movie it
entertained me for the entire movie I
didn't even notice like how fast the
movie had gone because I was entertained
the whole time which is a good thing the
fact that I was entertained because it
was so bad it's not a good thing
right I can say this this movie has an
element to it where if you go into this
movie knowing that you're about to
experience a movie that probably isn't
all that great that is definitely trying
to be the whole Twilight thing but at
the same time it's also trying to rip on
Twilight if you go into this movie
knowing that you probably aren't going
to hate your life as you watch it it is
a perfectly watchable movie on that
level
a guilty pleasure type movie where
you're recognizing wow this movie sucks
let's just laugh at it but yes the movie
has a lot of problems with it and my
biggest problems with the movie are that
even though it's trying to in a way
spoof the whole thing of this whole
vampire Harry Potter trend that's going
on lately the things I didn't like about
it is that it also falls into the same
cliches all those films have like love
triangles like you know forbidden
romances with instructors and people
you're not supposed to be with and it
has all the same stuff that those movies
have as well even though it's trying to
be a satire on those films and it's
trying to be like that sometimes it also
does the same old tropes that those
films do it also has a guy who looks
exactly like Edward Colin from the
Twilight movies I mean he could be like
his stunt double
this feels basically like Mean Girls
with vampire right that's exactly what
it feels like actly pretty much what it
feels like and then I started like
picking the movie apart and like
watching this shots and just watching
how badly it had been chopped
together it'll take a fight scene and
then I remember turning to him and going
that sounds like when I hit punching
bags right it the sound effects weren't
very realistic and what you said about
the fight scenes is also another big
problem I have with the movie it looks
like people are like punching feet away
from their faces like they're not
actually making contact and it's cut
together in such a mish matched way that
when you're watching it you're like I
don't think anyone's actually hitting
each other and you know they're not when
you watch a movie you know stunt doubles
are good at what they do but these guys
do not look convincing in these fight
scenes it's trying to be a little more
like hey guys there's gonna be fight
scenes - there's gonna be vampires and
you know wolf creatures fighting that's
cool right but it doesn't look realistic
the movie is trying to be funny it does
have some moments where like okay that
was a little bit clever there's a
likable lead performance from the main
girl her name is Zoey
Deutsch or something like that guys yeah
I thought she was okay in the movie she
looks a lot like Rose Byrne from
insidious the mom from insidious had a
very similar appearance to her there are
some elements of the movie that I was
surprised that actually aren't
completely crappy where you can sit down
and watch it and laugh at it but it's
also trying to set up a large amount of
sequels because I guess according to you
there's six books yeah means that
they're and from what I read
very briefly I haven't read the book
which this just actually kind of made me
want to read the book so I can kind of
do the comparison is that pretty much
the first movie that we just saw is
pretty much what is in the first book
okay so it's it basically did it okay
job summing it up I guess apparently but
the problem with this is that I don't
really think this movie is good enough
in any way to warrant sequels but
without spoiling anything the movie has
to have a sequel to explain many plot
elements that are just left hanging and
I don't think that's going to happen
because I don't think it's gonna make
enough money I don't think it's good
enough at all to warrant more films and
so there's all these plot points and are
gonna be resolved I'd bite your tongue
you said that about Smurfs that's true I
did say the sparks wouldn't make money
and look what happened to that we're
getting oh we're getting a whole bunch
of those but my thing is like I I'm ami
I'm talking about the Smurfs I'm sorry
I'm sorry more than likely all those
people who bought the book are gonna go
see the movie and they're gonna take
their friends with them which is gonna
make people like me who've never read
the book Oh read the book I need to read
the book so I can understand what I just
watched but we were the only people in
the theater yeah so there's hope for no
more of these so on the note of possible
sequels from this film if they do make a
sequel for it please please get a
different screenplay writer if you go
into this movie knowing it's bad you can
probably watch it and laugh at some of
the elements to it it's definitely
trying to be a satire of the recent
vampire trend but it's got the same
cliches in it so it doesn't always work
and it's not clever enough in my opinion
I'm gonna give the movie a d-plus I do
think that you can watch it on a guilty
pleasure like level but for the most
part a lot of the filmmaking elements of
it just kept bugging me I'm also gonna
get some movie see - for the fact that
it really wasn't well done at all I mean
the screenplay just was so bad and then
the direction of it was so bad all on
its own
I'm gonna give this an a for and how
entertained I was for the entire film
but it's still a c-minus movie just it
was so bad that it I can understand and
I can understand that because the movie
a movie like the room is so friggin
horrible but I can watch it and be like
you know what this is bad and I'm
entertained by it still I'm not going to
recommend that you guys check out this
movie you probably weren't going to
anyway but if you did see the movie or
if you've read the book let us know what
you thought of it
let us know the comparisons thanks as
always for watching guys and if you like
this you can click right here and get
stuck Minh eyes